and
I thank those soldiers and commanders of the
Wagner group who made the only
right decisions and did not resort to
fratricidal bloodshed and
stopped at the last line
[music]
today you have the opportunity to
continue serving Russia by concluding a
contract with the Ministry of Defense or
other law enforcement agencies, or return
to your family and friends.  wants to be
able to go to Belarus this promise
will be fulfilled
airfield an armed rebellion in any
case would have been suppressed by the organizers of
the floor despite the loss of adequacy everyone
could not help but understand this. They understood,
among other things, that they took criminal
actions to split and weaken the country,
which is now confronting a colossal
external threat to
unprecedented pressure From the outside, when our comrades are
dying at the front with words not a step back
[music]
we knew and know that the vast
majority of the fighters and commanders of the
Wagner group are also patriots of Russia, devoted to
their people and state,
they proved this with their courage on the
battlefield liberating the Donbass  they
tried to use Novorussia in the dark against
their brothers in arms with whom they
fought together for the sake of the country and its
future. Therefore, from the very beginning of the events,
on my direct instructions,
steps were taken to avoid
a lot of blood
[music]